welcome back to Piers Morgan sensor from
New York I am Mike Tyson I've done an
extraordinary life of Triumph and
tragedy on both the front and back pages
he was the King of the Ring 44 Knockouts
and Undisputed World Heavyweight
Champion and for me the greatest boxer
of them all he's always unmissable
television the last time I interviewed
him it looked like he'd just be knocked
out himself
and then just want to do this I'm
planning on doing this for a charity
exponent and I think I'm capable of
doing that and that's what I want to do
but there have been concerns raised
about the fact that you are two men in
your 50s uh fighting each other without
protective headgear what what do you
think about those concerns
I think it's very wonderful that we're
fighting together that the fact that we
should have
well I can see you laughing there uh
Mike Tyson hey thank you for joining me
again you look a lot perkier today than
you did then Mike what was going on last
time
Hey listen I was I had hurt myself at
that particular time I guess I was
training something to happen I hurt
myself and
I I'll be seeing some painkillers from
My Wife and after I received these
painkillers
I was just uncapable of articulating
anything it was just a mess
people thought I was so boring as an
interviewer that I'd literally driven
you to sleep
[Music]
it was my fault everybody it was my
fault I need you to take the rap for
this one mate because I got killed for
that it was like Morgan you're just
sending people to sleep what's the
matter with it uh it's great to see you
again mate first of all how are you we
I've been watching you fighting it was
fantastic and the next thing I saw
you're in a wheelchair because you've
had bad sciatica blow up and stuff how's
your health generally yeah
man it's Splendid right now I've been
training every day I've been working out
I've been slightly watching what I'm
eating I feel wonderful
well that's great to hear um I want to
talk to you about a number of things but
first of all I want to talk to you about
uh Ukraine uh the reason being that I
went out there recently and I met with
both the Klitschko brothers two great uh
World Heavyweight Champions themselves
one is the mayor of Kiev the capital
city of Ukraine fighting to to save that
City his brother has actually been on
the front line occasionally as well what
do you feel about that that these guys
that you know have been such great
champions in the ring are now literally
fighting for their freedom
yes I I I'm I'm a great deal of respect
from those two fighters
and their champions in the fight for
their country as well
what do you feel about this war Mike
what do you what do you think should
happen
I think um it should it shouldn't be a
war anymore
do you think that well Putin did was
wrong
I don't know what Putin did
but I I don't think they should be
fighting
what about domestic politics here in
America Mike there's a lot of turbulence
a lot of people very angry at the moment
possibly made worse by the pandemic in
being locked away and not being able to
see loved ones and so but a lot of anger
in society what do you make of that
I believe during all
um political competition
is always ugly
but do you feel it's getting worse do
you feel like tribalism between people
is getting worse at the ability to
listen to other opinions and not get
furious is getting worse
I think everybody
and if
um she just work together
and build a conglomerate
how do we do that do you think
okay by trusting and loving one another
look how far we came since the 80s
and we're going to continue to go
further and further I'm really I'm
really positive and about this country
let's continue let's go in the future
right A lot of people are negative about
America why are you positive
um it's the country in my home I believe
in it and I believe it's going to really
um flourish after this pandemic is truly
over
how did you find the pandemic might
being locked locked down and not able to
see loved ones and so on
well
I don't like if I could say and be
permitted I really
um flourished during the pandemic I
really um
that's when I became a great um
advocate for charity
because that was just very grateful what
happened during the pandemic why were
you grateful
and because I was able to help people
that couldn't be helped right
in what way were you doing that
I'm just charity food on the line
coach jacket
um book bags
back to school programs
it's quite a shift for you isn't it to
go from the baddest man on the planet
that was your fighting title that's what
your great coach customer wanted you to
feel so that you were Invincible in the
ring you go from that guy to a guy who
in a very difficult time for the world
uh was so Keen to help everybody else to
to be charitable towards them
well I had I had a great trainer to
teach me how to be a great fighter
and now I have a great teacher to teach
me how to great
um
humanitarian
when you think about your journey Mike
your life how you've how you've evolved
as a human being
what place have you reached now are you
happy in yourself
hey um I'm very happy and I'm very proud
of myself
I I never understood my accomplishments
as a human being until last year perhaps
I never took myself serious and last
year I tried and it turned out really
well
what did you learn about yourself what
have you what have you worked out about
yourself
that was a scared little boy for a long
time
and you're not scared anymore
no because that scary little boy is
really vicious and mean and scared
how have you found peace would you say
my family
that's my greatest accomplishment
being a father being a husband
yeah I'm just the whole the whole thing
man
how do you spend your days now Mike
my days yeah um I do it I do it I do
anything I want
what's an average day for Mike Tyson
these days
um first thing get up worked out for two
or three hours
come back take a shower eat my breakfast
most of it is
um I don't know plant-based
and then um I may may go to work with my
wife and may do some interviews
listen I had some great interviews
yesterday
's X
tiger
and Leslie Jones
well I didn't know I kicked ass
yesterday I did it I did a great
interview with you in your hot box for
your podcast it was fascinating yes you
did a great one great one and you're
always welcoming too I would love to do
it again we had an amazing fascinating
chat but I would say to people that
you're a very you're a complex human
being but you've got a massive heart an
extraordinary work ethic and I don't
think I've seen many people who've
evolved as a human being more than you
have given the tough upbringing you had
to where you've come to today
hey I just think of it from this
perspective
the great the greatest talent that God
gives you he gives you a lot of flaws to
go with it as well
do you think all great human beings are
flawed
in order to succeed they have to be
flawed
they have to experience some kind of
shame in their life
that won't allow them to be in the
position they believe was overwhelming
to them psychologically and emotionally
and physically
who are the people in history Mike that
you
most respect for whatever reason
Alexander the Great
um Elijah Muhammad
um
Jesus Prophet Muhammad Moses I have an
array of great people that I like
flavius Bella Ferris it's just so many
people that is
I don't know Charlemagne Pippin
Charles Martel you know I can go Ray Ray
of people who I admire Genghis Khan
Kubla King it's just so many great
people I love
elephant I look I read about them every
day
what is the what is the trait in a human
being you most admire is it an ability
to bounce back from adversity
well that's good too that's really
flamboyant and people think it was great
but a human being his greatest ability
is the ability to love
Mike I'm going to take a short break
come back I want to talk to you about
this extraordinary incident on a plane
where for some reason oh yeah a very
annoying passenger decide to to well
annoy you and he got he's come up with
us we'll talk about that in a moment
welcome back to Pittsburgh when I censor
from New York
um with Mike Tyson formerly the baddest
man on the planet but now a very
different man as we've just established
mate you're on a plane minding your own
business when another passenger for
reasons that continue to baffle me
decided to go to Let's remind you as
what happened
hey hey
Mike Mike come on let's go turn that way
here you go no I guess they're watching
it right now
Mike that incident ended exactly how I
expected it to once the idiot started
mocking you in that way uh what were you
thinking as you sat there when this guy
was doing what he was doing
first of all I came from this place
where I um it was called hippie Hill
where at least 60 000 people were there
and we're all smoking cannabis okay so
by the time I'm on the plane I'm high
hungry and tired okay and this guy keeps
um antagonizing me right and then
I came to my fences
and kicked
[Laughter]
I know I didn't kicking that but my my
My Bodyguard jumped on top of him and I
was fitting My Bodyguard
which I'm sorry
[Laughter]
what I imagine you've achieved Mike is
that nobody will annoy you on a plane
again
no listen that guy was just being um
irritant really
it's good
and you have to hit me with a water
bottle that my wife remind me of right
yeah I'm a completely pathetic Behavior
you shouldn't have been doing it do you
get a lot of this kind of stuff when you
go around
oh I I out of 10 people I may get one
how many do you deal with
quite a few but I may only have to put
my hands on one
I can't even can't imagine it I can't I
I can't play like that because my wife
gets mad my wife is so mad when I'm
playing chilling like my sense of humor
well your wife is definitely thinking
I'm gonna get canceled or something
well your wife is a delightful lady I've
had the great pleasure of meeting her
um and do you think do you think she
keeps you out of trouble now Mike
well I think she thinks she keeps me out
of trouble I'm just always with her so
that's why I'm not in trouble
but if she wasn't with you more people
would get a smack
no I don't agree on that I guess I would
my wife always told me to be nice when I
go outside so I would take that advice
and be nice
what's the secret to true love mate
excuse me what's the secret of true love
bad memory
[Laughter]
are you are you a romantic manner
big time yeah
because you're you know your wife I've
seen you together you're very much in
love with each other how do you how do
you show your love for her
may I buy a house
[Laughter]
make me love you
oh I didn't listen man I'm busting shots
I help her as a parent and we co-parent
our kids simultaneously every day
and what what kind of values might do
you try and teach your kids
excuse me what kind of values do you
teach your children
you have to be spirited and haven't gone
but never give up and and you're still
with life is just a long line of puzzles
that need to be solved
and then without that um competition
spirit
people are not going to do well and they
have to know about competition because
without competition and train them they
give in under the slightest struggle
right so I've been talking about this a
lot because I think we are creating a
soft environment for kids which doesn't
help them you know at school now if they
come last in any competition they get a
prize you know it's always about how
they're feeling if they lose they're not
allowed to lose anymore and I'm like
exactly
the same like there's a scene in Rocky
which I love in the sixth movie when
Rocky finally has it out with his son
and he says to look life is really tough
you know and it's going to hit you and
hit you and hit you and it's not about
how hard you can hit it's about how hard
you can get hit and get back up and keep
moving forward and I thought that was a
really powerful scene uh what do you
think of that did would you is that your
kind of philosophy
yes it is a hundred percent only one
thing is different it's a small it's
just a small fundamental difference and
that is once life hit me I'm gonna hit
life back yes
yeah I mean that's that is a I I don't
disagree with that if people hit you why
should you take it and that's always
been I know your mantra
I mean yes
who I am
Mike various stages of your life and I'm
just me right and you've never I've
known you a long time and I find you one
of the Most Fascinating People I know
you've had periods in your life where
you've been unbelievably rich like half
a billion dollars and so on you've had
other times when you've had no money
when have you been happiest with with a
lot of money or actually is money
irrelevant to your happiness
well I was happy both
um incidents
but it was just a part of my growing
stage
um
I um I wasn't experienced with my money
when I was younger I'm more experienced
now
when you uh I think it's 25 years since
you bit Evander hollifield's ear
and I did read so long yeah certainly 25
years yeah it's a long time right
I agree
do you know what happened to it to that
bit of his ear
but then in the fight then you um it was
able
obvious for you to see me spit it out
wasn't it yeah I just wonder what
happened to it
I don't know um I think they picked it
up and they put some I don't know what
it was a mile to hide
and I gave it to him in a commercial
I read somewhere that he'd made 30
million dollars from posing for pictures
pretending to bite people
listen
I don't know it was 30 but it was more
than three that I got since
um fine for
I've actually got a picture of you
trying to bite me it's on my Lou wall
hey
Hey listen that's the new
um that's the new gimmick picture every
time kids ladies men elderly men elderly
ladies take a picture make my hand take
a picture of this stuff and um
I'm happy to be able to do it
well you left my ear alone I'm I'm glad
to say uh Mike you're you're in great
she didn't pay me for it
that's completely true uh one quick
question before I let you go Donald
Trump uh we we think may run again for
president you backed him last time would
you back him again
Hey listen
I'ma do what I want to do when he runs
for president
but it's gonna be nobody else business
you're not going to say either way
there's nobody business what I say but
I'm gonna say something
it's getting your head above the parapet
on politics more dangerous than getting
in the ring
no it's just ridiculous it's like
if if I don't like you I don't make the
whole country not like you um
and I might send you to jail too
I mean it is it is ridiculous and what's
also ridiculous Mike is that we can't
have an opinion anymore right you're on
a show now called Piers Morgan
uncensored you can say what the hell you
like but you try and say some things out
of this environment and people want to
cancel you
it's like uh what is this um I don't
know this fascist if the government
don't like you the corporate world
unlike you is that is that called
Fashions it's fascism yeah it is
oh yeah that's what it is then it could
listen if certain people don't like you
oh he's a bad guy I'm not gonna let it
work for my company no more and he gives
you a bad name to all the corporations
and you can't make any money just
because there's one Corporation doesn't
like you
absolutely right it's it's absurd the
way Society has gone Mike I could talk
to you all night but I've got to leave
it there thank you very much for being
with me and for being so completely on
fire compared to last time I'm just so
glad that you did you fall asleep it
means forgive me please
me and my wife was viewing it and oh man
so I'm so ashamed my if more you've more
than made up for it this time thank you
very much great to talk to you take care
Bears all the best